Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast,
uh,
for Monday,
September 14th,
2015.
What's going on out?
Why Ya?
Um,
I know what you guys are expecting.
They're probably expecting me to talk shit about the Patriots winning and the
Steelers crying about the,
uh,
the headsets or whatever the hell they were crying about this week.
Why get,
why does everybody,
you know,
I love about giants fans.
They never bitch about the patriots.
They just beat us all the rest of you fucking sit there crying every week.
Anyways,
I'm not going to get into that.
Um,
I have a very special guest here,
one of my favorite all time comedians of all times,
but first I have to read his amazing a intro here.
Um,
Brian Regan,
everybody is going to be performing live at Radio City Music Hall and the first
time ever in the history of comedy central,
Brian,
you minds,
we'll talk at this point I've already said yes.
Um,
how many,
uh,
specials would you guess that comedy central has in their mountain?
Yeah.
Oh,
wow.
I probably quite a few,
but,
uh,
8 million,
seven to 8 million I think is a,
well,
this one,
I'm going to bet on the over.
I'm going to say it's 9 million,
9 million.
I liked that.
A 9 million specials.
This is the first guy who has ever had the nerve to a tape,
a standup special,
live on comedy central and he's going to be doing it and see if like on
September 26 at 9:00 PM live from one of the most legendary venues of all time,
Radio City Music Hall.
Um,
I mean,
I'm looking at the whole press release.
You got like,
you know,
five stars from Jerry Seinfeld,
Chris Rock,
Dennis Miller,
Joe Rogan,
Patton,
Oswald,
Mark Marin,
the WHO's who,
and uh,
we all love you,
man.
You are,
you are,
you've been,
what's it like to have been a comic's comic for a quarter of a century?
I,
it's a huge,
huge honor man.
You know,
when,
uh,
you know,
making audiences laugh is great,
makes you feel good,
but to also,
you know,
make the comedians feel like you're doing the right thing that makes you feel
even better.
I know my fun in this podcast is going to be torturing you.
You with comp compliments because I can tell him very senior,
hey,
what's it like to be a legend?
Brian talking about being a legend like that,
say,
yeah,
the other right into a bombing story.
Let me tell you what have I want to bombed.
And that wasn't so legendary.
Yeah,
no ma'am.
I've been doing this shit for 23 years.
I'm old now.
I am an old man now.
I know that every time when I tried to do stand up out in silver,
like I'm not saying the kids are bad,
it's just,
I definitely feel like,
wow man,
I feel like that that generation gap.
But you,
you've been like,
since I started,
um,
for those people like unfamiliar who'd been living under a standup comedy rock,
like,
like Brian basically goes out and for 90 straight minutes it sounds like a jet
is landing.
How hard guy kills and he never,
and unlike me,
you couldn't be the more polar opposite of me.
You don't,
you,
I don't even think you say heck no,
sure I do.
You say that,
but okay.
But still I do some hex and some dams,
but to joy act is like airtight like nobody can met.
No one can be like,
oh,
you know,
he's just a,
he's just what?
He's just writing perfect jokes for,
I'm sorry Brian.
I hate the torture with this,
but there's no other way to go with this absolute master.
You're very kind,
very incredibly kind and I cannot thank you enough.
That's very no eye contact.
Very.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I remember I'm going to keep going here.
I remember when I,
when I first started headlining in the late nineties,
um,
the legend back then was when you booked Brian Regan,
you would do two shows in one night and you would do to completely hour plus
totally clean,
absolutely destroying sets.
Like you had like the [inaudible] set in the be set and you had like there,
there was always this,
this urban myth.
He's got two notebooks.
They're both filled up once,
once,
so first show and once the second show he's doing the,
literally the guy's got two hours and 40 minutes of a level material.
I called it the idiot and the oddity,
oh those were the two,
the two shows.
There were two different one hour shows and I would go to a comedy club for like
a month and um,
and I would alternate them.
And the idea was if somebody came out and they liked what they saw,
they go,
wow,
he's got another one.
Maybe we'll come back and see the other show as well.
So now did that come about because back then when you are coming up,
like you had to be like anointed to do a special and nowadays you just need
somebody with the camera and you can put it up however you want it.
Like back in the day HBO had to say like,
you know what,
you're one of the six people that were picking this year.
Or I don't even think comedy central is really making too many specials,
uh,
back then.
So I was just wondering,
did you,
like you wrote a special at that point,
did you just say to hell with,
I'll just keep writing.
Like how did you end up with that much material at one time?
Actually,
well just because I,
you know,
I'm always trying to write stuff,
but it came about because,
do you remember when people were starting to do the one man shows?
Oh yeah.
Like Rob Becker defending the caveman,
you know,
they would take a stand up and then kind of make it into a little story with a
beginning,
middle and an end.
They got a few laughs.
You sit down behind a desk.
Yeah,
I moved.
Right.
Backers is great,
but there were a lot that were just,
you know,
seemed like kind of repackaged,
stand up,
you know.
And people were telling me,
well you should do a one man show you.
She should do a one man show.
And I'm like,
I like stand up.
I like the way stand up works.
I don't wanna I don't wanna like,
you know,
do a joke and then have a serious point and then walk across the stage.
And says,
I have a tear coming out of my dramatic lighting.
You know what's so funny,
I totally to that because I've had so many people were like,
my dream was always,
I just want,
if I could sell out Improv's that was the dream.
If I could,
if I could just go,
like I to me,
when I was starting out,
when somebody said,
oh,
I have a Gig in Houston this week or I'm in Minneapolis this week.
Like to me there was nothing cooler than that.
Like this guy gets to get on a plane and fly and people know who he is and he
gets to go in there.
And back then was you get to where the sport coat right?
And you get to go out and be and be a comedian.
I just thought that that was the coolest thing ever.
And I don't know how you feel about this one when,
whenever,
um,
you could have like the greatest special lever and then they're always just like
a,
it's a,
any TV and he moved like four.
It's,
it's always looked at.
Um,
it's got this weird thing where it's standup has really respected by people,
but then it's also looked at as just like this stepping stone into,
uh,
you know,
doing like,
uh,
I don't know,
like a sitcom or be in some sort of actor or something like that.
And I always just,
I always thought like,
no,
dude,
this is the thing.
This is the thing.
It always will be the thing.
I can't get fired from this.
I'm always going to be employed and it happens in real time.
There's no cut.
Let's go back and do it again.
And you're sitting in a trailer for 14 hours.
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
there are a few people who like it as an end result.
I want to say a few.
There are a lot of people who love standup comedy,
but yes,
for a lot of people it's a stepping stone to get into acting,
did get into a TV show or movies and that's great.
Um,
but I like it as it is,
you know,
and um,
people do always ask about the thing you don't have,
you know.
Um,
I just remember for years,
you know,
people coming up to me,
uh,
you know,
have you ever done the tonight show or whatever and,
and then when I hadn't,
and yeah,
I think,
no,
I haven't done that.
And you know,
you should call Jay.
Yeah,
that's there.
It's there.
Yeah.
Yeah,
no,
I,
I the the very,
the first year I was working at the comic Strip in Fort Lauderdale,
I was uh,
I work in the kitchen,
you know,
I would like cook burgers.
They would let me go on stage at the end of the night.
And a guy came up to me after a show and said,
um,
Rodney Dangerfield is playing down the road at the sunrise musical theater.
He goes,
why don't you go down there and open for him instead of this,
you know,
like,
like all it took has made it,
just know where the theater was.
Like I just walked down there,
oh,
is he in town where it was it that way?
So I just go down there and I opened for him in a theater,
didn't show where the apron a friend.
He is such a moron.
I'm neighborhood's been in the kitchen here and a comedy club.
I could go right down the road and open for Rodney Dangerfield.
Do you look for the suggestion?
Yeah.
Do you know what's funny?
In a way that mentality is how I got into this business was because I wanted to
be a comedian.
I didn't dare say it out loud,
but I didn't think it was possible.
Cause like when I was thinking about doing it was,
which is like the lady who started in the early nineties with the ladies.
I first started thinking about it but there wasn't any youtube,
there was none of that crap.
So to me I was living in Massachusetts show business was 3000 miles away.
Like it just seemed impossible.
And then I was working in a warehouse with this guy and he was just going like
do one of these nights.
And he likes staying up like glad he goes.
One of these nights,
I'm gonna take a shot of Jack Daniels and I'm just going to go down to an open
mic down the street that you know,
and just go up on stage and all of a sudden I was just like,
Oh wow,
you can just do that.
I thought I had to like,
you know,
get my teeth captain,
moved out to La and get a fake Tan.
Like I had no idea how to cook.
So I always,
I always had like a panic attack when I think about that.
I go and thank God I worked with that guy and thank God that he said that and he
took it out of seeming like,
you know,
it was like the Milky Way away.
He,
he,
he like made it like,
yeah.
Yeah.
Just go right down the street.
He just did the,
did that guy ever do it?
You know,
I don't know because we worked together such for such a short period of time.
I have no idea.
That's the only reason why I don't like telling that story because then people
like,
did that guy end up doing it?
Who would ever happened to him.
He's probably like some zillionaire banker,
you know,
I'm sure,
sit by a pool loving his wife and kids and his dog.
Just totally happy.
But it's just to me,
he didn't do what you did in life.
So he must not be happy.
When I,
when I first decided I wanted to be a stand up,
the only comedy clubs were in Los Angeles and New York.
I was in college in Tiffin,
Ohio and I knew I wanted to do stand up.
This is why in fourth year,
what year was this?
1980.
This is going way back.
Right.
And um,
so I knew I wanted to do it,
but comedy had not yet,
you know,
exploded.
It was only in those two cities.
So I was gearing up to having to move to New York City.
I'm like,
I didn't know
what's going on.
So when I thought I had to do in 92,
you actually had to do an 80.
That's what the,
yes.
And then I went back down to south Florida,
which is where I grew up.
And I open up the Miami Herald and there's an ad in the Miami Herald for grand
opening for the comic Strip Comedy Club in Fort Lauderdale.
It says,
Sister Club of the famous comedy club in New York City,
open mic night,
Monday night.
And I'm like,
Damn.
Like,
like it could not have been more beautifully perfect.
Like that's,
I don't have to have move,
right?
I don't have to move to New York City.
I can just fill up the car with gas and go up to Fort Lauderdale and try it.
And so it became so much more attainable when I saw that ad,
you know?
And that's where I started.
That's amazing.
I a very similar thing.
I hate me.
I made a new year's resolution in 1992 that at some point in the calendar year
of 1992 I was going to do an open mic.
That's how like shut down and shy was,
I was so nervous about it.
And the second I said that within two weeks,
uh,
in the school paper,
the Emersonian I went to Emerson,
it said,
uh,
Nick's comedy stop.
I had a contest,
it was an ad find Boston's funniest college student.
Wow.
And the whole thing was just,
uh,
just impact pack the club with a bunch of drunk kids,
right.
Buying drinks,
watching their friends bomb.
So I immediately,
I bought the paper,
uh,
might even been free,
I think,
I can't remember what the school paper,
I think it was free.
And then I brought it home and I just immediately called the phone number before
I chickened out.
And I was just like,
and
I remember so many kids from Emerson signed up that they actually gave us two
nights.
So I was supposed to go on at the end of something the last Monday in February.
And then they called up,
they said they had overflow,
would you want to do the first Monday in March?
And I was like,
okay,
like just to put it off.
And then I hung up and I felt like I pussied out.
And um,
but very like a similar thing.
So,
yeah,
I mean,
it's weird how things will leap out at you.
I mean that,
you know,
all the ad of all the ads in the world,
for fast food places and hotels.
And that ad for that comedy club like jumped off the page.
To me it was like,
holy shit man.
Um,
it was just,
it was just perfect.
And then I went there.
So it's 1980.
So you went down there.
So tell me about your first,
when you went on stage.
Uh,
well actually they want,
they wanted you to get there early to draw on numbers.
So I had to make the hour drive.
I was still living with my parents in Miami.
I make the hour drive up there and I get there.
I Dunno six.
And I know you were going to try it.
You pay,
I don't know if I,
I may have told my parents,
but I,
I didn't tell anybody to,
I didn't tell.
I don't even tell nobody nothing.
You know what I mean?
And it's like a mob hit.
Yeah.
It's like,
no,
I want to go up there and if I bomb,
nobody's going to know about this till the day I die.
So you seem so quiet,
you know,
what are you doing this?
You know,
I'm just getting a little dressed up and leave in the house.
So I go up there and they were like 20 comedians that I had to draw a numbers.
You had to draw numbers for your time slot.
I didn't know what any of this meant.
And um,
I drew I guess a good number.
You know,
I had like a sweet spot right in the middle and then right after the,
um,
the drawing all these other open makers who had done it before,
I guess it had been open like a month,
you know,
came up and said,
I'll trade you,
I'll trade Ya,
I'll trade you my number for your number.
And all I knew is whatever I was holding was valuable and I wasn't trading it
for nothing,
you know?
Nice.
You know,
I'm like,
they want this so I'm keeping it.
So I went on,
um,
and what,
they had three co headliners.
It was very weird.
And then they stuck the open miker is up in the middle.
I went on right in the middle of the show and uh,
I just completely blanked out on stage,
just complete,
wipe out blank,
not remember anything.
And judge,
you realize that walking towards the stage or when you got up and turned and
faced him,
what happened was I had every word memorized I had,
hi,
how are Ya?
Written down which hand you are going to wave where?
Everything I had,
hi,
how are you written down and memorized.
I walk on stage and that's the first time I realized how bright these lights
are.
Like I'm like wigging out that I can't see a soul.
And then I,
I started to say hi,
how are you in the microphone?
And there was feedback.
I was too close.
I went,
hi,
how are you?
You know?
No.
So I did my first ad Lib.
I said,
uh,
well I've already learned one thing.
I don't know how to work a microphone.
And it got a laugh.
Oh Nice.
And then my brain just shut off.
Oh cause you didn't,
you know what?
Because I had memorized hi,
how are you to the next thing and when I ad libbed yeah,
I didn't know where I was supposed to go after that.
And so they laughed at my ad Lib,
you know?
Wow.
I don't know how to work a microphone.
They laughed and I'm standing there going,
I don't know I could,
I blanked out blank blankety blank.
How,
how long before you,
I stood there for about 10 seconds,
which seemed like nine years,
like an eternity.
And,
uh,
I said,
well,
you're not going to believe this folks,
but I forgot my act.
And they laughed and I said,
no,
no arms.
I'm serious.
And they laughed.
It was like a twilight zone thing.
You learn in honesty works.
And I,
and I started ad libbing about how stupid I was for not being able to remember
my act.
I went,
ah,
this is great.
I spent all this time and effort trying to figure out something and I can't
remember nothing,
you know,
just off the top of my head.
And I started killing and I,
and I,
I started killing rolling about how stupid I was.
Um,
we were able to enjoy killing or you,
so I enjoyed it.
I,
I knew enough to go,
well,
all I want is laughs,
you know what I mean?
Um,
and I'm just winging it,
you know,
talking about what an idiot I am and how this drive I made and all this stuff
memorized and I can't remember a single thing,
but blah,
blah blah.
And I crushed it.
It will,
at least in my mind,
I don't fall for an open mic too.
That's crushing.
And then I said,
well,
I can't see myself ever remember in any of it.
So good aid.
And then I got this big hand,
I was going great.
I walked off stage and then like the,
the headliners,
one of them came up to me and said that that was a great routine about how you
pretended to blank out.
I said,
pretend they said that you really were winging out.
And I was like,
yeah,
but I was like in a fog.
And what did he say?
You should definitely come back.
Was He supportive guy?
I forget who it was,
but he was supportive.
He said it was really funny.
And um,
you know,
what was great for me is that my next time I went,
I remembered my act and just ate it,
but hilarious.
But I had the memory of knowing how to make people laugh from the first time
that just kept fueling me to just keep going back.
What do you think would've happened if you just did your act and that first
thing didn't happen?
You completely ate it.
Did you have it,
you think he had an Indian to keep coming back?
I don't know.
You know,
I've talked to other comedians about this and,
and I,
uh,
what's weird to me is that most comedians I talked to say that they're ver very
first time on stage.
They did well,
you know,
and then didn't do well the second time or third time.
And I wonder how many potentially good comedians out there,
it didn't go well and just said hell with it.
Now they're working at a home depot.
Just crushing it every day.
Hey Guy I've ever met in my life.
And they just,
you know,
and I truly wonder how many people have just had the bad experience and go,
I need this.
Like I need a hole in the head,
you know,
I know because the first time,
first I,
my,
my first two were,
uh,
I did Nick's the,
the,
the talent thing and went okay.
And then I did stitches,
comedy club.
Uh,
and when did,
okay.
And those are both comedy clubs,
but the first time we did a room that wasn't a comedy club,
I've told the story a zillion times in the podcast,
but it was a Jack Lynch had this room,
uh,
Kelly's something or other and it was some bar.
And I went up and I,
and I absolutely just ate it wire to wire.
I said,
on the microphone,
Jack,
I'm bailing.
I said that to the host.
And all the communities went,
ah,
they collectively were like disappointing to me that I quit and I hated myself.
And I remember,
uh,
but I would say it never dawned on me to quit.
Maybe it was because I did well those first two times,
but I just never,
I was just like,
all right,
well what can I do to avoid that?
Right.
That awful feeling again.
But you know,
it's funny when I finally started getting a little bit funny,
I actually was doing one of your mannerisms and people kept giving me shit go
and you steal them from Brian.
It's like I'm two,
three years in.
Oh,
I'm going like,
no,
I'm not.
You're a little,
you're crouched thing that you do.
I was so influenced by you cause I had seen you like,
first of all,
everybody was freaking out when you will come into play,
Nick's comedy stop.
And everyone's always got to Brian Regan's coming.
You ever heard of Brian Regan?
And um,
and I was like,
yeah,
I had seen him a couple of,
I'd seen you a couple of times on TV is like,
you gotta see this guy.
And he's like,
every comic in Boston was going,
you got to see this guy.
And I was like,
I'm doing a dick.
He's room.
It's like,
I don't give a fuck and finish your set and drive in here.
And I came in and I caught your second set.
I still remember you wearing this red button down shirt.
You went on stage and you,
you were killing so hard like,
uh,
you know what people wiping tears away,
like fallen into the isles isles and stuff.
And it was just so like you probably the first big comic like traveling comic,
you came in,
you followed all the Boston heavy hitters cause you know how they used to love
sticking like yeah,
you know,
some legendary headliner with all the local references in the feature act to try
and barrier.
And then you went up totally clean and it was a combination of watching you
murdering and then seeing all the comics that I respected,
like turning into like audience members and j and they were doing that laugh,
like,
like love and stand up and then being like,
fuck,
why didn't I think of that?
And that was when you would do,
and like the prescription Lens,
uh,
when Sheila and cheering and all that,
it was just,
it was an amazing thing and I,
and I appreciate it.
I was so influenced by that,
that I started doing,
I'll act it out.
I was doing,
while I was doing like a little bit of,
when I would go into a punchline,
I would like drop down a little bit.
And um,
it took me,
I did that for about maybe eight months to a year.
I was doing that and it took me about seven years to get that stink off of me.
People go,
Nah,
he's stealing from Regan.
He's still from Regan.
And I was just like,
I was like,
oh,
it's two years in.
I didn't know what I was doing,
what we're going to,
we've got to learn from something.
We got to watch him.
Yeah.
It's just a huge honor.
And thank you.
So I was actually,
I was doing you a little bit and,
uh,
and then I,
I,
they,
fortunately I had guys like,
uh,
you know,
Veloce and Norton and Patrice and all of them,
they teased me out of it.
We used to all,
we used to all sit there and trash each other going,
you know who you're doing and who you're doing it.
At the time I used to tell Patrice,
she was doing a little bit of Fred Sanford when he was going like,
and it's kind of kind of do like that thing with his face.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
well thank you man.
Now you,
I don't want to let,
I very much appreciate the good words.
Yeah.
Well look,
I won't,
I won't torture you anymore compliments,
but a little,
so how did you come up with the idea to do a special live?
I mean that's uh,
well,
you know,
um,
you were saying about comedy central does a lot of specials with comedians and
I've done a couple of,
with,
uh,
a couple with them in the past.
And,
uh,
you know,
I just,
I just wanted to do something different,
you know,
you know what I love about it is the thing I hate the most about doing a special
is afterwards when you have to watch the footage and edit and look at yourself
and listen to yourself.
I've always,
for the most part,
throughout all the specials I've done,
the few that I've done is I just,
whatever's show felt better.
I just go,
just take that Shell and whittle that down to whatever time they need because I
don't want to sit there and look at both shows.
Then it's twice.
I don't,
I don't want to fucking deal with any,
I hate it.
I absolutely hate it.
And I avoided the way I do like a term paper.
So back in the day.
So I was thinking about how your,
you're not going to have to do that.
You just going to go out,
you're going to do it and it's done.
And then another thing too is like you only time comics do a special where they
only have one show as if they don't have any budget.
You clearly,
you know,
at this point you can afford to tape two,
four,
six shows if you want it to.
You're only going to,
you're going to do it all in one.
Um,
what is the game plan you got going into that as far as like,
is there,
is there any like mindset that you're going into before that?
Like,
all right,
Brian,
just go out there and have a good time and,
uh,
some shits the bed,
you know,
dress it and keep plowing for,
I mean,
what are you going to do?
It,
it,
it's weird,
like,
I don't want to overthink it,
you know what I mean?
Like,
uh,
on the one hand,
I just,
you know,
I want it to be a show just like any other show.
Did it just happen to be some cameras in there and some people out there and TV
world watching it,
you know.
Um,
but at the same time,
I,
I want to have a couple of things going on.
Like I've been talking to my manager.
It's like all it takes is one idiot,
one idiot in the audience that you know,
wants to,
uh,
you know,
have this be his moment.
You know,
it's like you can't watch golf.
You can't watch golf without a guy hitting a tee shirt.
Yeah.
And he just go,
Geez,
what are you really that starved for attention?
You know,
like what are you going to go home and listen to yourself?
That was me.
I yelled,
go in the hall,
getting old,
getting where they say they all say it too.
It's like he came,
come up with something original.
It's just,
you know,
so
I have this little fear,
not a big one.
Cause my,
my,
my audiences are pretty damn cool,
you know?
But all it takes is one idiot in the audience who's like,
Oh wow,
it's going to be live.
I can do something that I,
you know,
I can get some attention for myself.
So,
but then if you trash them,
then it should work.
What that would actually do is it makes it like really unique as far as like if
somebody were to do that and then you were to trash them,
um,
even if they were to kick them out,
like live on the thing.
I don't want to talk about this too much,
but you have a great crowd anyways to give anybody any ideas.
But um,
okay.
Actually the way you're looking at that,
and you know,
when I was trying to think,
you know,
it's not like whenever I go do a show,
I just do the show wire to wire and I don't screw up any jokes.
You know what I mean?
It's just when you're recording it gets in your head like,
oh my God,
the documentation of that joke,
I flubbed this word.
And it's just like,
you don't care when the cameras aren't there.
So I would think that you would just get into a fucking,
you know,
this is just a documentary,
my performance of this hour on this night and this is how it came out.
And then you just go out there is that we're going to do,
yeah.
Well,
it's been a while since I've recorded an hour.
The last thing I did was about five years ago,
and that was,
um,
a CD.
I get,
I get antsy,
man,
when I get material,
I want to,
I guess,
you know,
a lot of people get material and they go,
wow,
this is good material.
I want,
I want to keep doing it.
I get to where it's like,
I don't want to do it anymore.
Yes.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
wow,
this is really good.
I'm sick of it.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I want to read,
I like to record it so it's there.
You know what I mean?
It exists,
but now I can move on,
you know?
So that's one thing I'm really looking forward to is this material that I've
been kicking around for the last four or five years.
And,
uh,
I look forward to it as nailing it down and then being done with it the week
that it's probably
gonna be more fun for me.
Like just starting to play around and,
and,
and get it back into,
uh,
some different stuff.
But I'm really looking forward to it.
But as far as the jokes in Iraq right now that you hate and you're actually
thinking that,
oh my God,
not you hate,
but you just so sick of talent that you're like,
I can't wait to record this.
Yes.
So I can just be done with it.
Start bumping up to that.
And I,
and I try to resist it and fight it and then like,
as soon as I start feeling that way,
I try not to do that bit for a month or two,
you know?
Yeah.
So that when I redo it,
it feels fresh.
And this is a challenge because I'm coming up on this special and I need to have
it in my bones would degree but not so into my bones where it's like you're a
machine up there.
You know what I mean?
You don't want to suck the funny out of it,
you know?
So it's,
it's a title.
I always know which one's subconsciously,
I don't even realize how much I hate certain jokes by the end of them.
Um,
is when I got one,
once I do this special,
it's just naturally the ones that you said,
you don't even make the choice,
the ones that you hate,
you just never do them again.
Right.
And I always think like,
wow,
man,
I must have really hated that joke.
I must have really been sick of doing that thing.
But uh,
you know,
it's funny to me is a,
it's just like in your normal progression,
you know,
you come up with a bit,
some new thing and you're excited about it and you,
you know,
you have your hit list,
right,
of,
uh,
here's something new.
I want to get to hear something relatively new.
I want to get to,
and you know,
and I'll look over that before I go onstage,
but I don't have a list of the bits that I'm dropping.
They just fall away.
Oh,
they just fall,
you know,
if there's something like you say about your subconscious that just goes a,
I've had enough of this one.
Yeah.
And it's just gone.
And then you,
and then a year later you think could go,
oh wow.
I used to do this bit about such and such and I just,
it just fell away and he never did it again after my special.
We got to take a real quick break here so I can do a little bit advertising
here.
And uh,
I almost did the radio thing.
I was thinking to do that.
We're here with Brian Rigor,
like,
like people don't look,
listen to these things,
wired or wireless.
So I'm going to do a little bit of,
you got to listen to me read out loud here.
Everybody and I will be back in a second.
All right.
Every body trunk club trunk club gets you a close in a trunk.
Yeah,
Trunk Club.
Everybody's shopping is awful.
Who has the patience for crowded stores?
Lace they do or the time to run?
Uh,
I fucking hate computers.
You know,
something.
Every fucking motherfucking time I tried to do anything on these fucking,
you know,
I've got a brand new fucking computer and somehow it's synced up to my fucking
phone.
So every time I have a text message he goes,
Dang,
Dang.
And half the time it's behind.
I already saw it on my fucking phone.
I don't know.
I don't even understand these things on any level.
I know
[inaudible]
setting.
He'll go into my settings.
You'll figure out how to shut it off.
Trunk Club.
Everybody shopping is awful.
Who has the patience for crowded stores or the time to try on 10 pairs of pants
that don't even fit?
Well,
why don't you look at the sizes and pick a color for Christ's sake,
you need 10 of them.
All right,
but here's the problem.
You still want to look great.
Oh,
I want to look great.
And with Trunk Club,
you never have to set foot in a horrific mall again.
Please include all of the following points during your read.
What do you think?
I'm going to skip over stuff.
Why would you include that sentence?
You know,
I'm going to read it.
A trunk club takes the hassle man out of shopping by shipping you a trunk full
of clothes that fit perfectly and make you look like 1 million bucks with all
the new fall styles@trunkclub.com slash burr.
You answer simple questions about your style preferences,
Sti,
this and are assigned an expert stylist.
They'll curate clothes from the best premium brands and you approve of what you
like.
The hell is this?
Get it out of here.
Uh,
I just,
and just like that a trunk arrives on your doorstep filled with handpicked
closed.
There were hand sewn by children and Elsa Salvatore that are perfect for you.
Try them on.
Keep what you like and easily return what you don't in their prepaid trunk.
This is not a subscription service so relaxed.
You only paid for the clothes you keep from your trunk.
No hidden charges,
just great clothes.
Get started to tay.
Get started today.
And Trunk Club will style you for free man.
Plus free shipping both ways.
You only have to pay for the clothes you keep to take advantage.
Go to trunk club.com/burr one last time.
That's trunk club.com/burr for a trunk filled blue clothes.
You'll love wearing.
Oh,
here we go.
Boop,
boop,
boop me undies,
me undies.
No more sweaty balls,
but who do to me undies me undies,
wash washing with concentrated at all and get the shit stains out of your
crutch.
But there'll be no ball sweat cause they're nice and dry.
Get yourself a pair of me undies and your balls will feel like they're velvet.
Oh yeah.
All right me undies.
We all know how sexy confidence can be and that confidence comes from being
comfortable.
But how can you feel comfortable?
Have your balls is stuck to the side of your leg.
How can you feel great if your is wrinkling and riding up Mondays gets it.
And that's why they've created the world's most comfortable underwear.
We had some of the smartest scientists with some of the sweatiest balls in the
world
to solve their own problem and now they're passing that knowledge on to you for
a daily dose of confidence.
You wear underwear everyday,
that's turned 65 days a year of rain or shine.
You need,
well sometimes you wear two pairs if you work out right or if you have an
accident.
Um,
you need to be extraordinary without an insane price tag.
You need it to be an extraordinary thing and the same price.
Tag me undies understands this and that's why they've created the world's most
comfortable underwear,
luxury and half the retail price you find anywhere else.
When you look good,
you feel great.
It's a cliche because it's true me undies understands this and that's why the
design underwear that makes you look and feel fantastic.
A note,
modelle is pound pronounced model undies is the motto of fabric that is,
is made from model of fabric that's twice as soft as cotton for the life of me,
I don't know why they don't have an accent on which syllable I'm supposed to.
I was supposed to a stress.
Okay.
Mardel
okay.
Madell maybe this shit that evidently makes you balls not sweat.
That's twice as soft as whatever underwear you're wearing right now.
Me undies has tons of colors and styles and the only place to get matching pairs
for men and women.
They even release a new design every month.
I were fill in the blank,
design parentheses,
black stripes,
tie dye,
et cetera and parentheses plus.
We all know that paying for shipping.
I actually got I where the free ones they sent me.
And you know what?
They're great.
Especially when you're playing hockey.
You know what I mean?
If you don't want to go like a,
you know,
you don't want to go commando,
they fit nicely underneath you.
A little hockey pants there.
I heard Wayne Gretzky warm in the 90s.
He got him first.
That's how good he was.
He had,
he had me on his back then.
All right,
this is getting way too long.
Um,
plus we all know the paying for shipping sucks.
So Mandy said,
remove that from the equation.
All orders in the U S and Canada,
Canada shipped for free.
Mandy's even as a money back guarantee.
If you don't pay for you,
if you don't love your first pair,
you get to keep it for free.
Well,
why would you keep it?
You don't like it.
You get to throw it out,
but no charge to you.
You literally have nothing to loose offer slash call to action to sweeten the
deal beyond these is offering you.
Yes,
you 20% off your first order at [inaudible] dot.
Fucking calm on.com/burr that's a special offer just for my listeners and
wherever else they advertise with.
Make sure you go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird to get 20% off your first
order and so that they know we sent you.
All right.
I love when they say shipping is for free.
It's no,
you've rolled it into the cost of whatever the fuck you're selling.
You know Jesus.
All right.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody.
Hey,
okay.
Can you stop shaving with an old razor?
For Christ's sake?
It's gross.
Why are you torturing yourself with a gross old blade week after week?
Oh,
that's right.
Probably because you don't want to shell out 20 bucks for a pack of new ones.
We'll relax.
Calm down.
Your prayers have been answered.
Dollar Shave club.com has the row has revolutionized the way that men,
Shay,
but dollar Shave Club,
you can shave with a fresh blade as often as you want because they deliver a
whole sleeve.
Amazing raises for just a few bucks a month.
Their razors are so good.
Millions of guys have joined.
Even the billion dollar razor corporations are freaking out because instead of
lowering their,
they're bloated prices,
they're trying to fool you into,
I can't read anymore,
man.
My eyes,
I can't see shit.
I like this conspiracy theory.
Um,
even the billing dollar razor corporations are freaking out,
but instead of lowering their bloated prices to trying to fool fool you into
milking the same blade for an entire month,
and that's gross.
They've price gouged us for long enough.
God Damn Right.
They have never go back to squeezing weeks and weeks of shaves out of a
disgusting rusty blade.
Joined Dollar Shave club and use a fresh blade whenever you want.
It feels amazing and it's a third of the price.
Join the millions of others who figured out a smarter way to shave.
Join Dollar Shave club.com right now by going to dollar shave club.com/burr
that's dollar shave club.com/ [inaudible] I love those guys because that was
such a fucking rip off.
I thought about that years ago.
I'm like,
why is this little pack of horseshit blades?
Why is it so much fucking money?
You know what I mean,
but I didn't have the entrepreneurial spirit of this Guy Christ.
They could've made a Zillion,
Huh?
All right.
Let's keep going here.
Two more.
Everybody.
stamps.com everybody getting your mailing and shipping data,
what?
Getting your mailing and shipping done can seem like a no win situation.
Go to the post office,
take going to the post office.
Takes up valuable time.
Sorry guys.
I took a red eye last night.
I'm even worse than usual.
Leasing a postage meter,
expensive with multiyear commitments and hidden fees.
Luckily I know a better way.
What is it you might've asked or might not have asked?
stamps.com just picturing you're driving to work,
zoned out,
not even listening to me with stamps.com buy and print official US postage for
any letter or package right from your desk.
Using your own computer and printer even gets special postage discount.
She can't find it.
The post office plus stamps.com is more powerful than a postage meter at just a
fraction of the cost.
You can save up to 80% compared to the postage meter annual.
Avoid those time consuming trips to the post office.
I use stamps.com to send out all my,
uh,
posters whenever I'm going to whore myself out on the road.
You know what I mean?
Stand out there and have people with sweaty armpits who are taller than me.
Rest that hot armpit right on my shoulder.
Right now.
Use My last name.
Birth for special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to
$55 free postage.
Do not wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
you click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and you type in birth.
That's all there is to it.
That's stamps.com/burr.
Now slide stamps.com enter burp.
Sorry.
And finally,
lastly,
but not leastly legal zoom,
everybody.
Hey,
you shouldn't have to choose a random lawyer who charges expensive hourly rates
when you need legal help,
should you.
But the legal system is so complicated.
What other choice do you have when you need help with your business or want to
protect your family?
Well,
you can start with legal zoom.
They make it easy for more than a decade.
They provided a way for regular people like you and me to confidently navigate
the legal system,
legal zones,
not a law firm.
And that's how they provide such a great value.
That is a weird sentence.
Yeah.
You know,
we'll help you with your legal style.
We're not legal people,
but yeah,
that's why we're so cheap.
Hey,
I'll fix your,
I'm not a mechanic,
but dude,
I'll do it for 10 bucks.
There's gotta be,
there's gotta be an answer to this.
And the next paragraph,
legal zoom is not a law firm and that's how they provide such great value.
They don't rely on charging you by the hour.
Instead,
you'll get transparent pricing and customer reviews so you know exactly what
you're getting up front.
Well,
that's a good thing.
If you need help with incorporations Llcs,
trademarks last,
oh,
I get it.
If you do this through a lawyer,
they rip you off.
They're just,
they specifically do this.
I get it.
Sorry.
Legal Zoom.
Uh,
last wills,
living trusts and more legal zooms.
The smart choice,
they got the right people on hand to answer your questions.
That,
and if you need legal advice,
the network,
their network of independent attorneys can provide the straight forward guidance
you need.
And most states don't let legal hurdles,
hurdles become an excuse.
Go to legalzoom.com today to start your building your own future.
The right way to save even more.
Enter bur bur in the referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com Promo Code Burr.
And that's it.
And now we're going to go back to Brian Regan.
As you can tell,
probably at this point,
he can't stand when I compliment them,
you know,
so I'll do it here when he can't hear it.
He's one of my favorite comics of all time and he's,
he's just the best and he's the best,
nicest,
most humble is fucking guy.
Ever.
Absolutely loved this guy.
Here's more Brian Regan.
Right?
All right.
And we're back.
Um,
so I was one of the tell that story.
Uh,
you know,
um,
one of the coolest things,
it was the first time,
like,
I really got to hang out with you and meet you.
I was playing,
um,
I was playing the comedy works in Denver,
one of the great all time rooms.
And uh,
you were playing like the,
the United Center of the Pepsi Center or something in Denver at this you play
like with the avalanche play her assumption red rocks,
red rocks.
Yeah.
Will you two shut that video that,
yeah,
like unbelievably 8,000 seater.
And after you did just show,
you still took the time to come in and catch my late show.
And at that point,
I don't think I had really four.
I'd met you a couple of times,
but I never really got to hang out with you.
And right before I went on,
someone goes,
hey,
just so you know,
you know,
Brian Regan's hanging in the back,
he came in and wanted to check out,
you said,
and it was the most ridiculous honor.
I can't believe it.
Then I was thinking like,
don't fucking go down in that crowd.
Like he did 1995 it seems like
he's doing me.
We both filthy word.
Hey,
wait a second.
No,
I'd be like,
no,
God,
like filthy.
Yeah.
Um,
and then we ended up hanging out and you were so complimentary and nice and uh,
and also something that I loved was you would like me,
you were over 40,
but hadn't quit drinking.
I can't stand people that just can't,
he can't fucking handle alcohol.
I mean,
right.
I should talk right now.
I'm going like,
I shut it down every once in a while for like 70,
75 days a,
uh,
by the time this podcast comes out,
I'll be on like day 71.
So.
Well,
you know,
it was funny,
in the middle,
in your set that night,
you said that you weren't drinking.
You said,
uh,
you know,
I don't,
yeah,
I'm not drinking now or something like that.
So I was thinking,
Oh man,
we're not gonna be able to have a couple of cocktails after the show.
And then we went out to the bar afterwards and I said,
you know,
I,
I know you don't drink and you go and you were like,
Whoa,
hold on.
But you,
boy,
yeah,
no,
I was just like,
okay,
if he's having a drink,
I got to have a drink of Reagan.
It's not fucking way,
I'm not doing this,
but
take times off because I find a,
like one of the things that I cherish about being a standup comedian is the free
time that I have,
um,
to pursue whatever the fuck I want to do either just sitting on the couch.
Like right now,
you know,
it's a Saturday when we're taping this and I'm taping three college football
games,
which I probably won't watch until like Monday or Tuesday.
And I just loved that I can just have a Tuesday.
Then if I want to get up at nine and have an English muffin and then just watch
three college football games in a row,
like I'm some assistant coach watching game film.
Like I got to break them down for somebody.
I just loved that.
I that I can do that.
But the,
the,
the dark side of all of that free time is I can go out and get hammered whenever
I want to and if I don't watch it I will start drinking again.
Like I did when I graduated high school with,
I just remember like 10 days after I graduated high school,
my mother just walked in,
classic her just really stoic and right to the point was your father and I think
you've done enough celebrating
it was all she said.
And that was her way of saying,
dude,
you're a fucking lush and you can end up in the gutter.
So grading.
Yeah,
well I mean
I was going out to like like two,
three,
four o'clock in the morning.
It was so funny cause I was young.
I would go on out,
we'd be absolutely fucking hammered in by eight 30 in the morning I was at my
warehouse job unloading trucks and all he had to do was make it to 10 when the
roach coach came and eat like us.
One of those sausages.
And then it just sort of leveled me out and I was fine.
And somehow I still had a flat stomach was fucking idea.
I didn't realize how lucky I was back then.
So that's,
that's why I,
I just go through periods of,
uh,
I just sort of shutting it down.
To me,
it's like,
it's a once every
two month thing,
you know?
Like I,
I know the night that I'm going to be able to get crazy and I'm careful and I'm
not driving and I don't,
I know I don't have anything to do the next day.
I mean,
like,
it's planned,
you know,
when you're younger,
you just wing it,
you know?
But now it's like,
it's in my calendar.
I'm getting racks on the 28th,
so I was friends,
you know,
I was hoping you could say once every two months you shut it down because you've
been going to like,
once every two months I drank.
I'm like,
Oh God,
I'm a mess.
But I got a,
I don't know,
man.
Like I go on the road with my buddies,
you know,
any of those guys are Jason Lawhead,
Joe Barden,
nick,
uh,
just these great guys that I go to the rose bowl with every year.
Paul [inaudible],
they're part of that,
uh,
that wave that came probably a couple of waves after my graduating class and
they're all just guys,
guys,
cigar smokers like to go to sporting events and all of that.
So it becomes like a sort of a standup tour and a little bit of like a Bachelor
party kind of Vibe,
you know,
minus of course the hookers and the blow and all that type of shit.
We don't,
we don't,
it's pretty main street.
It's all above the board legal stuff.
But um,
you know what the funny thing is is we get to the point like none of us will be
like,
dude,
we're not drinking tonight.
We're not blah,
blah blah.
And just,
there's something about the chemistry of all of us really,
and the f and the free time that we have that we just ended up getting
absolutely annihilated.
Like,
some of the worst nights of drinking we have is like,
dude,
we'll go easy to not just shut it down.
You know,
we've been hitting it hard the last three nights and tonight we do the show,
we get in bed,
we hit the hope,
we hit the fucking hotel gym and then we're on the road.
Sounds good.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
And then all of a sudden like,
you know,
La heads hosted and they'll come off and be like,
then I just have one heater.
Yeah.
All this.
And then,
uh,
and then it just,
and then went lap.
And as we're doing it,
we're laughing,
just laughing at ourselves.
So
it's like a game of chicken because I,
I have,
uh,
three different golf weekends a year with brothers and friends and it's just guy
golf weekends and,
um,
I don't even golf and that sounds awesome.
Oh Man.
[inaudible] golf during the day.
We played Texas hold 'em at night.
And,
um,
and you know,
I've got this bus,
you know,
that can we use for the golf weekends and it's kind of cool.
And sometimes we have a long cool,
that's fucking awesome.
It's cool.
I think golf would get hammered.
Texas hold 'em we got a tour bus.
It's kind of cool.
I got a poker table that was made to fit in the,
uh,
in the bus so we can play Texas hold'em while we're rolling.
So anyway,
you know,
you get in early,
you get on the bus early,
sometimes 7:00 AM you got a long haul to get to the,
and there's like 12 guys and it's like,
who's going to be the first one to crack a beer?
You know?
And because everybody's like having coffee and trying to look like they're sane
and normal,
you know,
they have a thing of orange juice pretending like we're normal.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
And then one guy goes,
a hand me a Budweiser and then the next thing you know,
12 Budweiser's are open.
And everybody just goes like,
yeah,
the first guy goes,
let me get it Budweiser.
He says
somebody
hello?
Literally here.
Right?
And then five minutes later they're in,
you know,
the second you just hear it open,
just like,
ah dude,
I
got to get one of those.
The last one I last run I did,
I did with Bartok and uh,
we actually had,
we actually went to the hotel gym like every day.
This is when I knew I was drinking too much and I had to kind of shut it down.
I was getting all fucking bloaty and shit.
And uh,
we,
this thing that we did every day,
that week after we worked out,
we came out of the hotel,
we went onto the bus and we had one bud light and we knew we were just gonna
have one bud.
Like,
cause we had a show and you know,
we're older guys,
you know,
if you have two drinks,
you're going to have to nap for nine hours.
You'd have to keep going and you can go for like 12 hours or you drink too and
you'd done.
So we would have one.
And because I knew I was just having the one,
I would like savor it.
Like,
I would just be like sipping it.
Like I was,
you know,
like when you stole your Dad's first beer and it was like one of the highlights
of the toys.
It was a fucking bud light,
I think.
I think I could figure out how to make that in a bath.
I can prohibition.
It was so fucking cold and delicious
just sitting there and they had,
you know,
the little TV,
they're on the bus and it just sat there and we would always put on like sports
center or something.
And it was a,
and then the hardest thing is when you finished was not in that next 10 minutes
to grab the next one.
I found that like,
if I just could get through that 10 minutes and I grabbed the water and I
started drinking that,
like,
whatever that chemical need of like,
yeah,
man,
let's have some more of that.
I would kind of wear off and I was able to do my show.
But,
uh,
it's something that,
[inaudible]
and I had my,
uh,
my brothers and,
some other friends out in Las Vegas where I live.
And,
uh,
they were on there,
they were on a golf weekend.
I live there and I was able to join them one night.
And it was one of those nights where I said,
you know,
I got a car for us,
and,
uh,
please call me.
I one of these not yet love to for that shit.
Oh man,
that'd be fantastic.
That's what he knows in alkie.
Call me in for the drink
when you're flying in.
Oh yeah.
So,
um,
I don't play Texas hold'em.
I don't golf.
I'll just be that guy.
I'll be the guy.
See,
I guilty.
I'll just open that first beer.
Yeah.
You'll be our designated first beer opener.
So we go out and it was my,
you know,
it like,
I,
I knew I could let loose,
you know,
I didn't have my kids,
I didn't have to drive by,
blah,
blah.
So it was one of those deals where you wake up the next day and you're like,
I don't quite remember at the end of the evening.
I swear I look on the,
I shouldn't be telling the story cause uh,
but I I
you're going to say is going to be any worse than I though
the my shirt.
I had a button down shirt that I had worn the previous night.
It's laying on the floor next to me on the bed on the,
on the floor next to the bed.
I pick it up and there's a tire mark across the back of it of car tire mark and
I don't,
I don't know how it got there.
I'm like wow,
I'm in a car.
Couldn't have run me over.
I mean I'm,
I'm alive.
I'm in bed.
I think he went a little will Ferrell.
I think you took literally a tire mark and I had to call my brothers and go,
how has a tire mark a car tire mark on the back of my shirt and they told me
that we're getting in the car and that my foot hit the curb and I kind of like
tripped and fell on my back underneath the car and like I might back ended up
against the car
tire.
They say,
you don't remember that.
US having to pick you up and put you in a limo.
And I'm like,
Damn Dude,
you fell under underneath the car?
Yeah.
Not into a car.
Not on a car.
I fell under it.
Fell under it without it moving.
It's now you've got sucked under.
That's not even possible.
Yeah.
That's a trick shot coming off a curb.
I don't know how you could do it.
They said I did some weird kind of flip around and then ended up with my back up
against the tire.
I'm like,
did you say I should go home after that?
I hope those were your lines.
Yeah.
It's time for him to get home.
I uh,
Joe de Rosa,
another one of my great drinking buddies.
He's got what?
He's got a buddy of his back home.
Uh,
you know,
when you have a beer and a shot,
which was one of my favorite ways to start out,
you know what I mean?
Just sort of set the tone and uh,
his buddy calls it Bingo.
Banga Oh yeah.
Which is the greatest thing ever.
To me.
He just go,
he came showed up one time,
he had a shot in the beer and Joe's just going like,
Hey,
what do you got going on there?
You guys,
you know,
Bingo.
Just kind of went like with the shot.
Fingal bank is one that I hit that one I would think go is the a would be the
shot bingos gotta be the beer,
right?
Well you do the shots first and then the beer in the beer.
So I would say bangled Bingo.
I was uh,
let me,
I'm trying to rewrite it
out on the road.
And uh,
this guy ordered a bunch of Irish car bombs.
Okay.
That's,
you drop it.
It's a big thick black stout beer and a big glass.
Then you take this,
what is it again?
And then you take a shot of whiskey and you drop the shot glass into the beer.
So the whiskey and the beer all together and then you chug the whole thing.
Yeah.
Alright.
Irish car bomb.
Well,
I got the name wrong and then the next time I was in that city,
all these guys get to,
it was Philadelphia.
And we all went to this like kind of cool,
rough Philadelphia bar.
And it was this guy who we had done the Irish car bombs within his friends.
So I'm trying to be like a guy and I thought it was a mud slide.
I thought that,
which is,
you know,
malaria chick chick.
So I'm trying to fit in and I went,
who wants to do some mudslides?
And uh,
my buddy who was the one who did the Irish car bumps and look at it and be like,
what the hell are you doing?
And I'm like,
no.
And then now I don't want to back down.
I'm like,
Oh,
you guys don't want to do mudslides,
Huh?
Like I keep pushing it and they're all looking at me.
So I go over to the bar,
you know,
mister big,
big,
big shot bartender over here,
seven,
seven slides,
settled all of us mud slides.
Please check drinks.
And then next thing I know we're doing like these late cream shots.
Oh,
they all went?
Yeah.
What?
Because they knew I was a comedian and they were like,
wow,
this is something this guy likes.
I guess know they,
they,
they don't want to
like undercut me.
And then my friend finally took me aside and know what the hell are you doing
here man?
And I went,
this is what we did last time.
He goes,
those are Irish car bombs,
man.
That's like a reoccurring thing with you.
It's like you're one of the smartest guys.
I know what you're always saying.
I'm a moron.
And all that type of thing.
You just always seen big,
heavy,
socially awkward.
You know what Terosa did that when he was in Boston,
hang,
hanging out with me.
We,
uh,
we did the shows over at the,
the Wilbur and afterwards,
all my,
my fucking knuckle head friends from high school,
all my great friends,
we were all drinking.
And uh,
in,
one of my buddies was really talking to Derosa.
They just saw the hit it off,
right?
And then he walked and he walked over.
He wants point.
He goes,
dude,
he goes,
what's up with you,
boy?
He goes,
what's up with the boy?
I go,
what are you man?
He goes,
he goes,
see,
I just asked,
you know,
what do you want for a drinky?
He wanted a white Russian and he goes,
dude,
he goes,
I'm all set with that guy.
So I'm laughing thinking he's just breaking his balls.
So later on in the night after we go to leave and I'm laughing,
I go to Rosie.
You know what's hilarious when you ordered that white Russian,
my buddy was breaking your balls,
balls to me saying he goes,
dude,
I'm done with that guy.
And then Joe just goes,
is how he stopped talking.
He wouldn't talk to me for the rest of the fucking night.
He was dead serious,
which killed me.
Cause that's such like a Boston thing where like,
like that's still like that.
That alone.
I imagined Phillies the same way.
If you were to order like the raw,
like someone's just,
I liked this guy,
this guy's cool.
And then all of a sudden you order,
you order something that's just a little too fucking soft over right.
You're dead to me,
mudslides much.
I should get together with him.
He will do some mud slides and some white Russians might white Russian chasers.
All right.
Bingo.
It was a sugar savory sugar salt or something.
Um,
all right,
let me,
uh,
let me make sure that I promote this thing.
I'm sure this went by and yet I knew it 44 minutes already.
Ah,
W before I get out of here,
um,
I,
I do want to bring this up to you.
We have to talk about the time when,
uh,
we decided for some reason I'm,
I'm,
I'm going to say it was my idea that we were going to do a show together,
you know,
and this is of course,
was,
was I was like,
not only is this guy the funniest dude ever,
he also likes to drink,
I have to do a weekend with this guy.
But I knew that you were playing like these giant places.
I think I was doing clubs or whatever.
And so I was like,
I'll open for,
I don't give a shit.
And then you were like,
hey,
why don't we just do a club?
You know,
the whole excuse was for us to drink.
So like why don't we just,
we'll just do a club.
We picked COBB's comedy club in San Francisco and it was just like,
you know,
for charity,
for charity.
So we figured we won't even make any money.
It'll just be an excuse for you and I to hang to get together and drink.
And I was,
I was going on first,
you were going on going on second and in,
and that's how I found out about the saint Jude's charity,
which I still donate money to.
And uh,
it just seemed like such a great idea in our heads.
It's like,
she's like,
yeah,
you know,
I'm completely filthy.
You're totally clean.
They're going to get the,
they're going to get the total standups,
white guy spectrum here.
And we went up there and I go on stage and your crowd was looking at me like,
Whoa,
who is this angry Leprechaun?
And I would say on a scale of one to 10,
I'd give,
my set was about a four.
And then you go on stage,
I'm going to,
I Regan's going to,
or at least rig.
I felt bad.
I was like,
Oh man,
I kind of bombed in front of his crowd and everything.
And then you go on stage.
I remember my sister was there,
you were killing her.
And then all my more on friends fans is sitting there looking at you like he's
on a stage for eight minutes.
He hasn't said fuck yet.
Yeah,
I don't,
I didn't feel like I killed either.
I mean I,
I felt like,
like you say,
I,
you know,
I did fine,
but I think we both did.
I like to do fine.
You know what I mean?
Flying is not what we want,
but you know,
it was like for a good cause.
But yeah,
I think it was like the two disparate,
if that's the right word,
you know,
audience who big a gap.
Yeah.
And I remember afterwards sitting in the bar and it was sort of like the
elephant in the room that we didn't want both wanted to address that we both
just sort of did fine.
And we would just sort of sitting there.
It was ruining our night sitting there drinking and then finally you brought it
up.
You just like,
like for three beers.
He was just like,
Hey,
what did you have?
How do you feel about that?
It's like,
I didn't think that went that good.
And then we would sort of stand in their little buzz going like,
yeah,
dude,
what the fuck it was for charity?
Like we said,
we didn't have to be there.
We almost got like pissed for a second though.
We just started laughing and realize that there was too big of a gap.
Uh,
well it was a noble cause you know,
it was weird about that too is a,
I think,
I forget what the charity ended up being.
American heart association or something like that.
I thought we did the saint Jude thing.
I,
it was one of those too,
but I remember like a cancer society something,
but you know,
we contacted me,
my manager's office contacted them that we were going to donate all the money
and like they don't say yes right away,
which is weird to me.
They're like,
well,
who are these guys?
And I'm like,
it's right.
You know,
and,
and they want to know a little bit about us.
It's like,
heck no,
we're,
we're giving money.
We're not asking you for money.
Yeah.
And it was like you have to figure out how to give the money away.
But you know what?
I think that was because it was probably the way things are nowadays.
Like if,
if they get associated with somebody yeah.
Who controversial or whatever,
like say Donald Trump the week he said,
you know,
I guess evidently all Mexicans are rapists and he was saying something to that
effect.
And,
uh,
if he was to donate them money,
like the blowback had gone to them,
like you're accepting money from a known racist and they're like,
hey,
we're trying to cure cancer here.
Right,
right,
right.
You know,
I probably shouldn't have brought that up.
Ah,
no.
It was great,
man.
It was a,
it was a blast and I,
and I thought we had a great time that night hanging out.
So,
uh,
it was cool.
Wow.
I would like to have done a little bit.
I'm not going to lie to you.
It's that sets you not,
it's still fucking bugs me.
I think I probably said that during my set.
Like,
Dude,
do you understand?
I don't have to fucking be here right now.
He's like,
I'm working for free.
Can you,
you know we should do,
can you give it up a little bit?
We should do like the opposite extreme.
Like I should perform in front of your crowd and then I'll get a one out of 10
and you get a 10 out of 10 and then you can perform in front of my crowd and we
need somebody to feature to Kinda sorta bridge bridge the two worlds like a
David Feldman is this unreal,
unbelievable comedian.
Unbelievable joke writer.
But he will out of nowhere to say Kentucky on stage maybe.
I don't know.
Are you a sports fan,
Brian?
I like sports,
but I'm always reluctant to say I'm a sports fan because then I immediately get
hit with a question I can't answer.
I grew up in Miami.
I'm a dolphins fan.
I like football and I like golf.
You know what's the great thing about,
uh,
you coming out of Florida?
Florida has a bad reputation for comedians.
Like they tried to say that a bunch of hacks come out of there and uh,
then you're always the go to guy.
They're like,
fuck you.
They're like Brian Regan.
It always named three,
I forget who the other two are,
but every city I think kind of just has three good ones every state at this
point.
I mean there's only like the top hundred right?
Comedians.
You got 50 states you got to go to from each state.
Yeah.
Who are the two from Rhode Island.
That's funny.
Everybody's got that.
Oh,
I was trying to steer the conversation towards sports because I've been
defending my New England patriots as they've literally become like the fucking
antichrist.
Uh,
the antichrist,
however,
however you supposed to say it,
it just now at this point,
like we just,
after the 9 million thing that we've been accused of,
of course just accused,
nothing has ever been proven.
Other than that,
we cheated for one game in 2007 where we filmed the jets and then a bunch of
people like,
well then you're super bowl championship shouldn't count.
It's like,
yeah,
they should because it wasn't against the rules for us to be doing what
everybody else was fucking doing.
We just ignored them and we cheated against the jets that we get ratted out by
fucking meant.
Janey.
Other than that,
it's just been a bunch of fucking hearsay and I was just hoping you would either
100% agree with me or 100% disagree with make and we'd get into an epic argument
about it,
but you,
you're into golf.
Do you watch tennis at all?
Did you see Serena last?
I saw that she lost.
Yeah.
That was devastating to me.
I hate,
that's why I hate watching tennis and golf.
Those are the two most brutal.
It's all on you.
It's like doing it.
It's like doing stand up on a late night talk show.
If you go out and fucking bomb,
it's Nike.
You're out there with somebody else.
It's just a hundred percent
trying to keep your emotions in check.
Like the first time I actually sat and I've watched a golf tournament wire to
wire.
I watched the masters in I think 2007 it was when the wheels came off with,
with Kenny Perry.
And I was watching that whole thing rooting for this guy and he's never won and
he's going to win his first major,
blah,
blah.
The guy was like three fucking holes away the wheel.
And I saw his kids go from tears of joy to,
to devastation.
Like the guy died.
And I later heard that he,
when he lost,
he didn't even talk to his family.
I'm sure he said a couple of words.
He just got in his car and just started driving.
And I remember being as a sports fan,
so upset that I actually sat and watched that happen to a fellow human being.
I felt horrible.
I felt like I was looking at it and getting an execution.
It's like watching an execution almost,
you know?
Um,
but I mean,
there are similarities between that and what we do.
You know,
it's like,
uh,
you,
you have a horrible set somewhere,
especially on TV,
you know,
but at least the least,
you can blame the crowd on some level.
You can stand and yell.
Alien could,
not on TV,
but in like a a at a comedy club,
I'll fuck you people.
You can do something to try to do something to at least some sort of,
I get you're better at that than I am a minor victory in it today.
Just have to sit there and,
and as people are commentating who don't nearly would never have the,
we'll have the skill to do what they're doing and just be seeing that guy.
Oh,
the wheels,
it just coming off right now.
You can see he's,
he's just visibly upset.
He's perspiring and they're just sitting there just giving play by play.
Nobody quiz you bomb as a comic is bad as it gets this nobody giving play by
play doing that mystery science theater thing as you're doing it.
That's all I'm saying.
So I,
I,
I like golf.
I actually loved tennis,
but I like watching somebody.
I went to the,
I was in France this year and I went to the,
uh,
the French Open finals and I was so excited to see Djokovich when the French,
and then he would have won on all four,
all surfaces.
And he would have become part of this short list.
And he won the first set.
And after he wanted it,
he looked over at his coach and he fucking did like that,
that tiger woods fist pump.
And I was like,
Oh man,
this guy is dialed in.
He's fucking dialed in.
He lost the next three straight.
Oh Man.
It was just,
it was,
and it was great to see that where Rinca guy when his first one.
But that's one thing that
is so great about sports is if you do win a championship or you do when
something,
you have that Eureka moment where you can jump up and down and celebrate and hug
people.
Most jobs don't have,
yeah.
Now that line in the sand moment,
you know,
where you can just go,
yeah.
You know,
you go to work a nine to five and you do what you're supposed to do.
You don't have some moment where you're just jumping up and down on your desk,
you know?
Um,
so I get to be that they should do that for people every Friday when it's like
four 59 and they're like,
well,
you know,
do that one minute left in the period like they used to do in the Boston Garden
and then that wouldn't be good.
Count down from 10
people,
got the goggles on,
spraying champagne and all that shit.
And then you go home for the weekend.
Well we did it,
you know,
we had a good week at work.
That might actually be a morale booster if especially if like some shit fucking
job.
I think that would be a great idea.
You have your week,
your weekly count down man.
You send everybody home in a good mood.
Absolutely.
Well Dude,
we gotta we gotta go.
I gotta wrap this thing up.
I got to do some more advertising here,
but it's,
it's been an absolute pleasure as a,
as a fan of the art of standup comedy to watch as much as your careers is.
I've seen it to actually,
you know,
when you came down to the comedy still comedy store,
the comedy works,
that that is still and always will be one of the biggest highlights of my
career.
And uh,
I will definitely be there.
What is the date of when you're a shooting it here?
Oh,
September 26th,
a Saturday.
Um,
nine o'clock eastern time and I don't know what time it will be on all the other
time zones,
but a nine o'clock eastern on comedy central.
Bill,
you're the best man.
I've stand up comedy special ever first.
Live special on comedy central.
I think HBO has done one.
I think Seinfeld did a live special on Hbo,
but this is comedy central's first one.
So that's,
it's incredible.
Thank you.
It's incredible.
Hey listen man,
I think you're great.
I've always loved your comedy.
I've always loved your perspective.
I love her saying,
look,
you're cursing.
I love your drinking.
Yes,
no man.
Um,
and so I just wanted to return the compliment man.
You're,
that's why we wanted to come down to see you because you're great.
Well I appreciate
that.
And next time you are boozing.
I don't play Texas hold'em or golf.
I'll learn the Texas hold'em golf.
I can keep it on the course.
Hit me up,
dude.
I'll fly in.
I fly and I'll tell my wife I'm doing a corporate gig.
Just I just won't show up with any money afterwards.
All right.
Please tune in September 26th at 9:00 PM on comedy central eastern time to watch
out of their first live standup comedy special with,
with one of the greatest comedians of all time.
Brian Regan.
Thank you so much for coming on,
Brian.
Thank you,
Bill.
All right.